[Musica]
nel cuore dell'Innovazione digitale c'è
un potenziale straordinario plasmare un
futuro in cui non solo la tecnologia
avanza ma anche prospera in armonia con
il nostro
pianeta
bella frase di impatto sensazionale
esattamente come l'ho chiesta chat GPT
un'intelligenza artificiale generativa
esperta nel linguaggio
naturale forse la più potente la più
famosa della nostra storia Almeno fino
ad oggi ora dovrete credermi e fidarvi
del fatto che il resto della
presentazione sia una mia
creazione l'evoluzione tecnologica È
inarrestabile oltre a GPT abbiamo tanti
altri esempi nella vita di tutti i
giorni che ce lo dimostrano come quando
per esempio andiamo in un ristorante e i
camerieri iniziano essere dei robot nel
modo in cui i nostri accessori e i
nostri
elettrodomestici iniziano a cambiare a
essere sempre più connessi e
interconnessi e quindi tutta la tematica
dell'internet of Things i videogiochi
stanno cambiando con l'arrivo di questi
visori possiamo apprezzare quello che è
il mondo della realtà
aumentata che ci permette di immergerci
in mondi digitali
fantastici Anche il mondo la musica sta
cambiando esistono già Delle Band
composte
da membri che sono in realtà Avatar non
sono persone vere che cantano ballano Ma
tutto questo è frutto dell'intelligenza
artificiale e sicuramente non possiamo
non parlare della guida
autonoma perché già oggi iniziamo a
vedere sulle nostre strade veicoli che
guidano da soli o lo fanno in parte
e è quello che di cui voglio un po'
parlarvi oggi della guida autonoma di
come
l'evoluzione della
mobilità sarà possibile grazie ad essa e
l'evoluzione che ha due obiettivi quello
della sicurezza e quello della
sostenibilità dovete Però sapere che
guida autonoma non si limita soltanto
alle macchine guida autonoma è guida di
veicoli che possono essere più sparati
dove semplicemente il veicolo impara a
guidare senza il bisogno di dell'essere
umano lo fa in autonomia da solo tramite
il software che viene sviluppato un
veicolo per esempio potrebbe essere un
piccolo Delivery robot che porta degli
alimenti nelle nostre città Ma potrebbe
anche essere un veicolo per fuoristrada
che viaggia nelle foreste nei deserti
riccios sabbiosi che appunto porta
materiale in questi scenari
ma non lasciamo fuori anche l'industria
perché anche i veicoli logistici possono
essere tramutati in autonomi e aiutare
le nostre aziende i campi sono davvero
tanti potrei parlarvi di come ci sono
animali robotici autonomi che possono
aiutare L'uomo in diversi compiti potrei
parlarvi dei droni per il monitoraggio
per la consegna di beni potrei anche
parlarvi D ambito Marittimo di come
anche le imbarcazioni iniziano ad essere
in qualche modo autonome ma vi voglio
parlare invece di quello che è il Racing
autonomo perché dopotutto dicono che noi
maranesi il Racing lo abbiamo nel
sangue che cos'è il Racing autonomo E
che cosa serve è una competizione non
diversa da quella di Formula 1 c'è una
grande differenza però qua non c'è il
pilota ma c'è un computer e è il
software a guidare il veicolo E sì ci
sono competizioni ci sono macchine che
gareggiano e quindi un software che
gareggia che cosa serve me lo chiedono
in tanti oggi il Racing autonomo ci
serve per fare
ricerca ci sono ovviamente tante cose
che sono in comune con la guida autonoma
stradale anche in questo caso il veicolo
deve identificare se ci sono ostacoli
altri veicoli imprevisti sulla propria
carreggiata lo deve fare per riuscire a
pianificare quella che è la traiettoria
migliore la più sicura per poi riuscire
ad andare a controllare quello che è il
mezzo
guidarlo quello che non è in comune sono
la velocità a cui lo deve fare perché
questi veicoli da
competizione arrivano fino a 250 280 300
km/h che non è la velocità a cui siamo
abituati ne nostre strade il Racing
autonomo è il perfetto esempio di quello
che noi chiamiamo un sistema di tempo
reale che è critico per la
sicurezza perché il software non solo
deve trovare una soluzione la migliore
che c'è ma lo Doe trovare in una
manciata di millisecondi perché questi
sono i tempi di
reazione quindi oggi lavoriamo a Racing
autonomo perché ci serve ricercare il
modo migliore per essere sicuri un
domani nelle nostre strade e poter
applicare i risultati di questa ricerca
ai veicoli che gireranno nelle nostre
strade e qui appunto il primo punto la
sicurezza Ma come vi dicevo il secondo
punto dell'evoluzione della guida
autonoma è quello della sostenibil
perché dovete sapere che chi lavora
nella guida autonoma punta proprio a
questo avere nelle nostre città nelle
nostre aziende veicoli che sono autonomi
significa andare a ridurre quello che è
il traffico ridurre gli ingorghi quindi
ridurre le emissioni ridurre gli
incidenti ridurre anche il numero di
veicoli perché il veicolo sarà un
servizio per l'uomo potrà essere
condiviso non dovrà per forza essere
parcheggiato potremmo rimuovere i
parcheggi D le nostre città Magari in
favore dei parchi per le nostre aziende
Vorrà dire avere delle dei veicoli che
sono più efficienti e magari di mandare
a questi veicoli delle operazioni che
sono pericolose per
l'uomo una domanda che viene sempre
sempre fatta
inflazionata nel nel mio ambito è bella
questa idea ma quando si avvererà e la
risposta da 10 anni a questa parte è tra
10 anni
ora non sono qua oggi per aggiungere la
mia stima ma chiaramente ce ne
accorgiamo non è ancora oggi non è
questo il giorno nonostante ci siano
tanti passi avanti giorno dopo giorno
già oggi in molte macchine possiamo
trovare dei sistemi di assistenza alla
guida che sono molto molto evoluti
tuttavia non è oggi quindi noi stiamo
lavorando a una mobilità che sarà
sostenibile senza però sapere quando
questa si avvererà Mh E perché invece
non farlo oggi quindi la sfida è questa
Perché invece non facciamo già una
ricerca che è sostenibile per potervi
rispondere Devo un po' raccontarvi Che
cosa significa fare ricerca nell'ambito
della guida
autonoma significa prendere uno di
questi veicoli e guidare per chilometri
Chilometri e chilometri senza una vera
meta solo per poter raccogliere dei dati
dati che sono
preziosissimi significa stare ore ore
ore davanti a un computer per scrivere
il software software che poi deve essere
testato Perché come ho detto la
sicurezza è uno degli altri obiettivi e
il software non può fare errori deve
essere simulato prima di essere messo su
un vero veicolo quindi in un mondo che
ricostruisce la
realtà ovviamente significa fare ricerca
di modelli di intelligenza artificiale
non uno no due ma 10 100 migliaia e
significa addestrare questi modelli con
quei dati Preziosi che abbiamo
raccolto elaborare i dati scrivere il
software testarlo simular addestrare
l'intelligenza artificiale significa
avere bisogno di una enorme potenza di
calcolo che ad oggi possiamo trovare nei
Data Center che sono giorno dopo giorno
Anno dopo anno sempre più grandi più
ricchi di computer sempre più potenti e
ovviamente avidi di
energia Quindi se facendo una ricerca
per una mobilità sostenibile in un modo
non sostenibile
m come per tante altre domande la
risposta è dipende e dipende dalle
nostre scelte non sarò io la prima a
dirvi che quella della sostenibilità è
una scelta che siamo chiamati a fare
giorno dopo giorno nella nostra
quotidianità nel momento in cui andiamo
a fare la spesa e dobbiamo acquistare
qualche prodotto prendiamo qualcosa che
viene dall'altra parte del mondo e che
deve fare deve attraversare centinaia di
chilometri per arrivare ai nostri
supermercati o magari un prodotto
italiano magari un prodotto locale del
nostro territorio a
km0 è una scelta che dobbiamo fare
quando acquistiamo un
vestito compriamo 10 capi dall'industria
del fast fashion o magari acquistiamo un
solo capo da un marchio che ne so
italiano con una produzione in Italia
con una produzione che è attenta sia
all'etica che alla sostenibilità magari
con compriamo un capo riciclato di
seconda mano o magari non lo compriamo
un nuovo abito perché non ne abbiamo
veramente
bisogno è una scelta che già oggi
facciamo nella mobilità quando ci
spostiamo utilizziamo un'auto elettrica
o un'auto a Diesel utilizziamo magari un
mezzo di trasporto pubblico un autobus
un treno o magari per tre gitti brevi
possiamo decidere di utilizzare la
bicicletta o farci una passeggiata beh
vedete anche nella ricerca Abbiamo la
stessa gamma di opzioni
ovviamente dobbiamo scrivere codice
dobbiamo testarlo dobbiamo simular
Dobbiamo creare nuovi modelli di
intelligenza artificiale per ottenere
ogni giorno ogni anno delle soluzioni
migliori ma per farlo possiamo adoperare
dei servizi di aziende che sono anni che
si occupano di sostenibilità che hanno
già creato dei Data Center che sono a
impatto zero o
quasi anche nella guida autonoma
possiamo utilizzare l'idea di riciclo
quando Pensiamo a una vettura autonoma
pensiamo magari a un veicolo futuristico
completamente diverso da quelli che
conosciamo ma perché invece non
sfruttare i veicoli che già abbiamo e
trasformarli qui in figura vedete una
macchina che da da carburante è stata
trasformata a elettrico Ma la stessa
cosa si può fare da una macchina che
viene guidata in manuale a una macchina
che viene guidata in autonomo e ve ne
Parlo per esperienza personale è una
cosa che già si
fa giorno dopo giorno dobbiamo lavorare
al nostro software quindi lavorare
ora dopo ora e quindi perché non farlo
magari in aziende che già oggi si curano
di come il proprio stabilimento viene
alimentato magari da fonti di energia
rinnovabile o ove questo non è possibile
magari prediligere il lavoro
remoto Nel 2020 è stato pubblicato
questo Paper questo articolo che viene
un po' considerato quello che è il
manifesto della Green ai gli autori di
questo articolo
cercano di spiegare alla comunità Come
si può fare ricerca nell'intelligenza
artificiale in un modo sostenibile per
semplificarlo i modi sono due il primo
punto è riuscire a quantificare Qual è
il costo della nostra ricerca quindi
riuscire a calcolare quello che è
l'impatto della nostra modello di
intelligenza artificiale il suo
consumo il secondo passo è utilizzare
questo costo per andare a validare
quanto è buona una soluzione di
intelligenza artificiale mettendola
insieme all'altro fattore che viene da
sempre utilizzato Cioè l'accuratezza
quanto è brava a fare un certo compito e
vedete la chiave è proprio questa non
sto dicendo che fare una scelta
sostenibile sia sempre facile cerco di
dirvi che non dobbiamo vederla come un
ostacolo piuttosto come la misura del
valore delle nostre azioni che siano
azioni che facciamo quando facciamo la
spesa quando ci muoviamo quando
lavoriamo O quando facciamo ricerca
e è una deve diventare una nostra
priorità perché lo sappiamo già è
l'unica opzione che abbiamo se vogliamo
preservare il mondo in cui viviamo oggi
come una responsabilità perché lo
facciamo per noi non per altri Cioè per
noi e per altri ma per i noi di oggi per
i noi del futuro e per la nostra
discendenza l'evoluzione tecnologica È
inarrestabile l'evoluzione sostenibile è
nel mie mani quanto nelle vostre
[Applauso]
[Musica]
grazie